-This is Jared Leto right here!
-Hey!
-Welcome back!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on, look at this guy.
Let's talk about
"House of Gucci."
Man, you are unbelievable
in this film.
You're amazing, not only the
action and the acting,
but the look.
They did such a great job.
This is you as Paolo --
Paolo Gucci, look at this.
Yeah, that's Jared.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I know -- were you --
I know you get into
your characters
when you do your films.
-You could say that.
-Yeah, we once had -- we once
had I'd say probably
70 percent of the jokes
on our show...
-Maybe.
...and 30 percent
Jared Leto at one time.
But I mean, I love this.
Do people recognize you?
Do they is go,
"Oh, hey, Jared?"
-No, I mean, walk around
New York,
it's pretty great because people
are so nonchalant here.
You know.
"Hey, Jimmy, what's up."
-Yeah, they don't care,
they've seen everything, yeah.
-They play it cool.
But I do have a lot of people
coming up to me
really interested
to see this film
because I didn't know the story
of the Gucci family.
I'm sure a lot of people out
here don't know
the story of the Gucci family.
-I didn't know.
-And it is shocking.
It's a shocking story
about this dynasty.
It is just Machiavellian and
Shakespearean and all the ends.
It's just an amazingly --
-Yeah.
-It's amazing -- amazingly
complex story,
and really proud
to be part of it.
Ridley Scott, one of the best
directors in the world.
-Ridley Scott crushed this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He was -- this was kind
of outside his thing.
I wouldn't even see Ridley
doing this movie.
-You know, he can do anything,
you know,
from "Alien" to "Gladiator"
to "The Martian,"
and on and on and on.
The guy just made some of my
favorite films of all time.
And Al Pacino plays my dad.
-Stop right there.
I mean, I would freak.
Have you met him before?
-You know, it's funny
because I showed up
for the first day of work
in character and I went up
and I said, "Papa," you know?
[ Laughter ]
And he looked over and kind of
just skirted away from me.
I said, "Oh, maybe he's a little
grumpy, I don't know."
-Yeah, of course.
-And then, tried again.
I said "Papa, it's me Paolo,"
and he basically
shuffled off again,
"Like, who is this creep?"
And then someone whispered
to him, "Al, it's Jared."
And he turned around, he said,
"Oh, my son! My son!"
-My son! [ Smooches ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-My son!
-Everyone, it's phenomenal.
Obviously Lady Gaga
is fantastic,
but man, I'm not
just saying this,
Jared Leto, watch this dude.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Watch this guy.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Jared Leto and Lady Gaga
in "House of Gucci."
Take a look at this.
-You have a gift,
I'm telling you.
-Oh, stop.
Stop, you're going to make me --
you're going to make me cry.
Nobody has ever said that to me.
Nobody.
-Paolo, why don't you
have your own life?
-Oh, these are just mock ups.
I can't afford to get serious.
-With your gift and your talent
and your vision,
are you kidding?
Gucci needs new blood.
Good-bye 1930s.
Hello '80s, huh?
-[Indistinct] is right up
my guards.
-Paolo Gucci is coming.
-[ Humming ]
-That's Jared Leto everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Paolo Gucci, "House of Gucci"
is in theaters November 24th.